rappelle, j'ai toujours
détesté Noël.
- Comme une prémonition,
le créateur du film C.R.A.Z.Y.,
Jean-Marc Vallée, est décédé
le soir de Noël.
PIERRE EVEN, producteur de
C.R.A.Z.Y et Café de Flore
- C'est plus qu'une surprise
c'est un choc, en fait.
- Le réalisteur serait mort
de causes naturelles dans un
chalet à Berthier-sur-Mer,
près de Québec. Sa disparition
crée un grand vide.
DENIS VILLENEUVE, réalisateur
- Jean-Marc c'est un géant,
c'est énorme ce qui se passe.
- Tu vas pas publier sa maudite
liste...
- Son premier long métrage,
"Liste Noire" en 1995, attireles
c'est avec C.R.A.Z.Y que
Jean-Marc Vallée récolte
l'attention du monde entier,
en plus de remporter 10 prix
et 13 prix Jutras,
aujourd'hui appelé IRIS,
au gala du cinéma québécois.
- Il s'est rien passé.
- Fais un homme de toi une fois
dans ta vie, puis dis la vérité!
MICHEL CÔTÉ, acteur
- Lui il adorait les acteurs...
il était d'une attention
particulière au jeu des acteur
- Il reste toujours près
de la caméra, il regarde
ses acteurs et entre les prises,
il va leur chuchoter
à l'oreille.
- Et ses acteurs lui rendent
bien.
Pour la série Big Little Lies,
Nicole Kidman a
de la meilleur actrice au Golden
Globe.
comme Mattcomme Mattcomme Mattcy
qui a reçu l'Oscar du meilleur
acteur pour Dallas Buyers Club.
Ce dernier a été le premier film
réalisé par un Québécois à être
en nomur l'Oscarur l'Oscarur l'r
du meilleur film. La mort du
réalisateur attriste l'actrice
de "Wild", Reese Witherspoon,
qui a le coeur brisé.
"Mon ami, je t'a
envoie-t-elle sur twitter
La pianiste Alexandra Stréliski
écrit que Jean-Marc Vallée a été
sa bonne étoile :
"Tu es parti beaucoup trop tôt,
Jean-Marc. Tu laisses des traces
indélébiles dans nos coeur
nos âmes et nos inspirations".
Le réalisateur avait choisisa r
Dallas Buyers Club,
entre autres.
- Réparer le coeur humain, c'est
comme réparer une automobile, il
faut démonter chaque pièce...
- Jean-Marc Vallée a su faire
sa place parmi les plus grands
cinéastes.
- Un sens du montage incroyable,
une direction d'acteurs
impeccable, un goût pour
la musique et l'environnementso,
hors du commun.- Pour Denis Vil,
Jean-Marc était un ami, mais
surtout un pionnier québécois
dans l'univers hollywoodien.
- C'ét
Ce que Jean-Marc a fait, c'est
énorme, il a abattu un mur. Et
puis, on a pu traverser, moi
entre autres, grâce à lui.
- Le réalisateur
Vallée avait encore tant à
faire.
♪ Ils viennent du bout
du monde ♪♪ Apportant avec eux ♪
♪ Des idées vagabondes ♪
- Il laisse derrière lui
des oeuvres magistrales.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Montréal.